allez faut que tuarrêes de faire le
clown qui est là dit bonjour bonjour
entrere il fait
froid tlévision ouis où troué
ça dit ce que tu voulais faire comme
métier plus tard vétérinaire
papa il pe pas Assur on parle pas de ce
que tu as envie on parle de ce qu'on
peut faire d'accord Charlot qui a fait
rire et pleurer de rire est parti de ce
monde sur la pointe des pieds j'ai eu
une bon idée ouh là une idée qui va
changer ta vie je très bien comme ça moi
avec ta fille qui fera ce qu'elle pourra
et pas ce qu'elle veut vas-y accouche on
va demander de l'argent à un ami tu sais
qu'on a enterré chapeline hier qu'est-ce
qu'il tombe faire en prison tu es
sérieux là je suis monsieur Monet comme
le pas voler un mort tu coisses là tu
coisses comment peut-on tomber si bas
c'est pas une bonne idée que tu ces
comme ça au téléphone on dirait que tu
paniques ce n'est pas une plaisanterie
nous avons Charlie chap avec nous c'est
pas possible il est mort je vous dis
c'est nous qui avance son cé mais
écoutez passez-moi monsieur chapine s'il
vous
plaît monsieur je sais tout tout
préparé j'avis dû me laisser er là
dedans tu me trouves
R
on sortira cette histoire la tête
haute tu m'entends la tête
hauteire
Maly